foreign
[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
ymh live a very cool Christmas join us
we have ymh Originals special guest
Bobby Lee and a whole lot more a very
very heavy segment VIP package with the
great Josh Potter
if you don't tune in to our holiday
Extravaganza December 14th it's gonna be
jolly today's Monday December 5th and we
have a packed episode of the joke World
comedy update today with ymh and Tom
Segura announcing a brand new live show
with Bobby Lee another brand new live
show announcement for Matt and Shane's
secret podcast and Stavros announcing
his brand new podcast stavy's world all
that more coming up in this video but
first if this is your first time here
welcome to the joke World comedy update
every single Monday bringing you all the
comedy news that you need to know from
your favorite comedians your favorite
podcast all in one place if you want to
stay in the comedy Loop be sure to
subscribe to joke world right now turn
on the post notifications and download
this episode on Spotify or apple
wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show and leave a comment
to start things off Bobby Lee and ymate
studios are teaming up to present a very
cool Christmas streaming December 9th
and according to their description we've
got more surprises in store with brand
new ymh Originals never before heard
Christmas carols and our special guest
Bobby Lee and of course we always end
the show with our very famous heavy
segment you know how we do the ymh lives
and they have the heavy segments yeah
you've not shown up aheading yet no so
are you going to
well the last ymates live was back in
August that was the first one to feature
a guest with Tim Dillon now the reason
comedians love to do these live events
in this type of format is because
normally there's limitations and rules
on what you're allowed to show do or say
on the internet with YouTube and stuff
like that but behind a paywall during
these Live Events there's absolutely no
rules it's the wild west of Clips you're
allowed to show during the heavy segment
what you're allowed to do or say no
limitations so given that that is the
case I honestly can't think of two
better guests to have on your Live
Events other than Tim Dylan or Bobby Lee
well now ymh has done both I just want
to say I'm sorry I want to do the best I
can or the best version of who I am
right yeah but I just
okay oh you put the lifts in your shoes
this is great I feel like you're you're
standing up straighter I like it guys
you ready
the expectations for this live show are
already through the roof I'm definitely
going to be tuning in December 9th at
8pm tickets are already on sale right
now for ten dollars or for 50 you could
do the VIP package which includes a
pre-interactive live show with Josh
Potter and a VIP survival kit with a
custom ymh Christmas stocking a flask
shot glass and vomit bag so you get some
ymh merch with the live uh Josh Potter
show in the VIP package to me 50 for a
live podcast seems like a little much I
wish that there was a way to see Josh
Potter's live show without getting all
the merch for like 25 bucks or 20 bucks
that's more in my range of what I think
would be reasonable to charge for a live
podcast so I'm gonna go with the 10
version but if you want some ymh merch
for free well it's not free but if you
want this stuff go for the VIP you know
the first time I figured out Bobby Lee
was crazy was like the beginning of my
comedy career maybe like year two or
three I'm at The Comedy Store talking to
him uh-huh and he's like do you ever
take Elmer's glue and then put it on
your legs and just peel it off like no
yep he um he also he told me a couple
things that he made me swear it's a
secrecy that I wouldn't tell and I would
I'll respect that but it's he's wild
another big live show announcement Matt
and Shane's secret podcast will be going
Live December 14th starting at 8pm and
according to their description the time
has come the digital space of podcast
broadcasting is about to get disrupted
on December 14 2022 Matt and Shane
secret podcast is being streamed live
from Chelsea Music Hall in New York City
using groundbreaking internet technology
the show will feature one maybe two very
special guests smoke something drink
something and join the interactive live
chat as the Bros carve out an
infinitesimal sliver of History missing
this may pose a serious risk to your
mental health you could die from the
stress please don't die choose to live
instead join us
so that was definitely written by Matt
not Shane the Christmas tree lit up can
be a Sinister instrument when you're not
feeling well I've I've swallowed that uh
that living symbol myself and my darkest
hour just cried kitchen
all right uh I wish it was went long
enough that we could edit out the whole
first half of that no way dude I've got
to go make sure if you don't tune in to
our holiday Extravaganza oh yeah I do
even though I'm not sure it's holiday
related but December 14th yeah
it's gonna be jolly super jolly time the
[ __ ] Uber's here yeah I'll do uh I'll
do part two of Jerusalem so for those of
you that do not want to die be sure to
tune in on December 14th they've already
teased that there's gonna be one to two
special guests but have not let on at
all who these could be maybe it's the
stuff Island Boys maybe it's some other
New York City comedians maybe it's some
completely random people that we have
never heard of who knows I don't know
what I do know though is this is the
first ever live event for one of the
funniest podcasts in the world so I'm
definitely gonna be there on December
14th at 8pm tickets are already on sale
right now for just ten dollars or if you
wait till the day of the show because
you're a lazy piece of [ __ ] it's gonna
be 15 that's the difference of five
dollars
or death or it's ten dollars fifteen
dollars or you die according to their
description so I'll see you guys there
I'll be in the live chat Stavros has
started his very own brand new comedy
podcast dropping episode one on YouTube
today of stavy's World featuring guest
number one Sam Morrell I remember when I
was like really young my friend Dennis
who's like a good friend maybe we'll
listen to this and his dad was also
named Dennis and his dad was rest in
peace a great guy
story
I loved his dad he was super funny he
was like literally we'd have to like
pick him up from the black bar he was
like the one white Greek yeah in the uh
black bar just carry him out he was so
funny yeah and uh I remember he we take
us to bars we were kids we just he just
kind of get us in there and how old are
we doing you like 14 15 19 20. oh okay
okay but I mean like
we go to a bar with him and he literally
just walks up to a woman and goes lady
what I wouldn't give to [ __ ] you up the
ass and we're like Jesus Christ what the
hell
what the hell is wrong with you
and and Dennis also was like what the
[ __ ] great pickup line and then
like I am so sorry that's so
unacceptable and she goes finally a
gentleman then she grabs me and makes
that with me and I was like You Gotta
Give me a wink I'm like he knew what he
was doing he just jumped on a grenade
for us
it's like the ultimate Wing man that's
awesome the first episode was hilarious
it was honestly gonna be hard to miss
with Sam Morel and Stavros just shooting
the [ __ ] on a podcast anyway but
nonetheless they delivered as a lot of
you know Stavros left his former podcast
come town just a few months ago to start
focusing on some individual projects and
a solo podcast where he brings on other
comedians seems like the obvious move
bro's camera is a [ __ ] potato okay
it's off the regular webcam okay I don't
I we didn't we haven't figured out how
to go live from the studio we built a
new studio and we didn't really remember
how to do that part so yes I [ __ ] that
one up that's on me I just wanted to do
a cute little live to tell you
[ __ ]
um that stavy's world the and the show
is out now go [ __ ] look at it go
subscribe
um
wipe the lens all right [ __ ] you guys
I'll wipe the lens
I'm being [ __ ] Cyber Bullied here by
my own chat
is that better actually it is a little
better
[Laughter]
this first episode earlier today the
account's already gone up a few thousand
subscribers with Stavros involved I
think it's safe to say this podcast is
going to be a big hit we're gonna do a
video later this week gauging the comedy
fans reactions and thoughts on this new
show so if you want to be featured in an
upcoming joke World video go head over
to our community section right now and
throw in your two cents about stavy's
world there's an opportunity right now
for all you guys to get 20 off one of
the coolest Brands coming out of London
they make the most comfy shirts in the
[ __ ] world these are the world's
first question all shirts meaning
they're 100 super thin super soft
organic cotton toweling great for days
at the beach great for traveling
absorbent no sweat stains literally one
of the softest things I've ever put on
my body also each shirt is designed
specifically for a location or event
down to the thickness the color and the
pattern obviously you can wear them
wherever you want but on top of that
five dollars off every purchase goes
directly to taking Plastics out of the
ocean some companies put Plastics in the
ocean this one takes them out of the
ocean fly London is rapidly becoming a
worldwide brand and the quality just
really speaks for itself if you look
closely you can see some celebrities
wearing the Playa brand LA like Jude Law
and Andrew Tate joined the Playa London
Revolution right now and not only will
you feel great but you'll also be
supporting a great cause get 15 off
right now using the code joke world just
in time for Christmas Guest spots from
last week your mom's house did not have
a guess it was just Tom and Christina P
two bears one cave was Tom and Jana's
Pappas flagrant had on Ari shaffir Ari
was also on to take her shoes off Sam
Morel was on stavy's world and whiskey
Ginger talked with fluffy even at the
end of the night when I said thank you
good night and the show was over and
their confetti flying and the cameras
are going and stuff like that as soon as
the music stopped I didn't get off the
stage I stayed on the stage and I
started drinking and then I said kicked
the music and I brought my friends out
on stage and the crowd did not leave
they stayed there and they celebrated
with me oh that's great man you know and
and then we just started sharing stories
I started passing the mic around we
started sharing stories you're not going
to see that in the special right you're
not going to see it in the special
because uh I think by the time I got off
it was about three hours and 10 minutes
and the special was 155 so they had to
chop off basically the the celebration
another hour of fun yeah and um I got
fined I got fined by the Dodgers by
Dodger Stadium because we went way over
there's running the light and then
there's what I did yeah you ran all the
you ran the lights at the Dodger Stadium
I ran all the lights of Dodger State
yeah this past weekend had on Neil
deGrasse Tyson The Joe Rogan Experience
also had some Neil deGrasse Tyson we
might be drunk talked with Al Franken
the Honeydew had on Nick Simons are you
garbage talked with Mateo Lane and Logan
Paul was on tigerbelly as far as new
Stam specials out right now we actually
have four this week which is more than
normal so buckle up here we go we're
going to start off with Aaron Berg
stands down it's right out right now on
YouTube and that's a full hour then we
also have Mike Crone and thick worm also
available right now on YouTube we have
Mateo Lane the advice special that's a
30 minute hilarious special that's
available right now on YouTube and then
lastly we have Sean Patton came out with
a brand new special on peacock and is
settled number one and according to that
description pen explores everything from
his OCD to his madhouse of an upbringing
and the broken yet unbreakable bonds of
his family so there are four brand new
specials for you guys to check out this
week let me know if I missed any in the
comments any upcoming specials that I
got to keep an eye out for or any
specials have came out in the past I
didn't mention on this show at all let
me know I want to include them all it's
just these come out so randomly so
frequently on such different streaming
services sometimes it's hard to bring
them all together special wise that does
it for this week's joke World comedy
update as always thank you so much for
watching this video and we'll be back
again next Monday with some more comedy
news but in the meantime we'll be
posting some other great content on this
channel comedy related they're all
comedy related channels if you love
comedy then you definitely need to be
involved in this channel you need to be
subscribing and liking and commenting
your personal opinions maybe some
opinions that you heard from other
people that that you would like to
replicate it doesn't even have to be
your own opinion it could be someone
else's just comment whatever you want
it's things falling over thank you for
watching
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
okay
these are getting ridiculous every week
these get get more and more out there I
hope no one watches the ends of these I
mean I do for retention rate and
algorithm [ __ ] but like
these Never End smoothly so thank you
for watching at all honestly and if
you've watched this far I owe you money
seriously goodbye
[Music]